in today's morning rounds how heart
disease is a major risk for pregnant
women today is the American Heart
Association's Go Red For Women day heart
disease kills nearly 400 20,000 women in
the u.s. each year it's the leading
cause of death among women the disease
is the number one cause of maternal
deaths a recent study found about one in
four pregnancy or postpartum deaths are
caused by cardiovascular complications
our dr. taryn and Rula who's a
cardiologist spoke to one woman who had
a potentially life-threatening heart
complication during her pregnancy dr.
nurullah good morning good morning
Jericka the mortality numbers are even
more staggering for african-american
mothers their risk of dying from heart
related complications is three times
higher than white women we spoke to a
first-time mother who was diagnosed with
hypertension during her pregnancy and
once she learned her condition could
lead to serious future complications she
changed her life around this was
Michelle amiibo in 2014 she and her
husband Marcus were expecting their
first child just like all new parents
they worried about the health of their
baby but amiibo received unexpected news
in her third trimester during routine
visit with her obstetrician about her
own health she told me that my blood
pressure was extremely high amiibo says
that moment changed her life forever
and it was pretty alarming when I went
back the following week and my pressure
was still high that's when I knew there
was something wrong amiibo was diagnosed
with gestational hypertension it's also
known as high blood pressure that
develops during pregnancy after 20 weeks
in severe cases it can cause
preeclampsia or eclampsia a pregnancy
complication that can be fatal to the
baby and the mother hypertensive
disorders can affect as many as 1 in 10
women and can increase risk of heart
failure heart attack and stroke I really
don't know what caused the hypertension
so I know I had gained a lot of weight
the only thing I knew was that I had
hypertension and then hopefully after
giving birth to my daughter everything
will go back to normal and it just did
not four months after giving birth to
her daughter's suraíh amiibo struggled
to get her blood pressure under control
her
weight skyrocketed and her new normal
was chronic postpartum hypertension and
a daily blood pressure pill you didn't
expect to have a diagnosis of postpartum
hypertension no and I didn't even know
there was a thing called postpartum
hypertension risk factors for
cardiovascular disease related maternal
mortality are race ethnicity age
hypertension and obesity women who are
diagnosed with hypertension during
pregnancy are then at a higher risk for
high blood pressure and cardiovascular
disease in the future the number of
maternal mortality --zz in the u.s. is
actually increasing dr. Kathryn Weinberg
is a cardiologist at Lenox Hill Hospital
we're seeing that there's actually an
increase in the number of heart attacks
during pregnancy and that number is
going up in the United States we don't
exactly understand why we also sometimes
unmask disorders that we didn't realize
were present before you're doing great
amiibo got serious about her health she
works out at least five days a week has
cut sodium out of her diet and portion
controls all her meals do you feel like
having your daughter helped push you and
motivate you oh absolutely yeah I want
to be healthy for my daughter but it was
also - for me I'm not just the rise mom
I'm a show - and I have to take care of
myself she worked hard for four years to
lose 75 pounds and since last winter she
no longer needs blood pressure medicine
when you think of heart disease you
think of heart attack you think of
stroke hypertension is a real issue and
cardiovascular disease while pregnant is
a real issue we have to get the
information out there for moms and for
families Michelle amiibo is now a
spokeswoman for the American Heart
Association and hopes her story will
help other women know the risks you know
one of the things she said to me was I
can't believe I was chosen to be a
spokeswoman because all I had was
gestational hypertension I didn't have a
heart attack or stroke and that just
conveys the idea that most women don't
really think this is a big deal and dr.
Narula what are some of the signs of
that hypertension and what should one do
we saw Michelle was able to lose a lot
of weight and she's eating healthier but
what what should people do well if
you're diagnosed certainly you need
close follow-up during pregnancy and
then I think one of the big things is
have
after pregnancy you really need to meet
with a cardiologist in three months or
so to go over all of your risk factors
you need to know your numbers the issue
is during pregnancy and even in general
hypertension can be silent so you may
not feel anything but certainly in
pregnancy sometimes it's hard to tease
out you may feel short of breath or have
leg swelling and you just think that's
normal pregnancy but sometimes it can be
a marker of a bigger problem so you need
to speak up and speak to your OB and
potentially you know get referred
further on to a cardiologist even women
the way Michelle is responded is so
impressive I mean are there ways to
prevent heart disease during pregnancy
well there's ways to prevent heart
disease in general we try to educate
people that 80% 80% of cardiovascular
disease is preventable so things like as
you saw diet and exercise and stress
management all of these things can go a
really long way Tara thank you very much
very impressive story